now how to balance energy security and
climate protection has been top of mind
for many people and leaders in 2021 with
energy security seeming to have been the
more pressing issue Russia's war in
Ukraine has triggered an energy crisis
which many continues and including
Germany are trying to mitigate with a
comeback of coal in countries like South
Africa are profiting from a global rise
in demand
they're on their way to a 12-hour shift
in the mines here in mpumalanga in the
northeast of South Africa coal is a big
part of life nearly a hundred thousand
people work in it and it accounts for 80
percent of electricity production but
its future is uncertain as South Africa
tries to tackle climate change
it's sad because there are a lot of
Minds which employ many people
if they close a lot of people would
struggle
the minds are very important in our
lives and also call because we even make
fire with it it is very useful
last year to help South Africans switch
its power production from coal to
Renewables Europe promised at billions
but that has changed since the West
sanctioned Russian coal amid the war in
Ukraine coal prices have soared and
South African coal exports to Europe
have increased nearly Eightfold since
the War Began it's a dilemma
I think we can run a dwell system coal
entering energy which will link his
capacity because what we've seen is that
we like in capacity with the amount of
low children we are having also with the
reserves that are still in the country
there's still a lot of reserves that
need to be obviously mined out and then
meant for electricity
South African fossil fuel companies are
profiting from record coal prices and
soaring demand so for now moving away
from polluting energy sources is once
again on the back burner
or for more on this let's bring in Simon
Miller he's an energy transition expert
welcome to the program Simon what does
it tell us about the green energy
Ambitions of industrial and emerging
countries when being confronted with
this emergency scenario that we're
seeing right now everyone just Falls
everybody falls back and they're heavily
carbon emitting ways
well I think it's very important to
distinguish the short-term immediate
response and the structural consequences
when we look at the short-term response
it shows us that we're still deeply
dependent on fossil fuels but if we
consider what does this mean
structurally I would say it's very very
robust that we will see a dramatic
acceleration of renewable energies why
they have the cost argument on their
side they have the energy security
argument on their side and the
sustainability argument anyway however
if we look at the immediate response to
the crisis of course we need to rely on
existing facilities existing assets and
they are there and can burn fossil fuels
so around the world this consumption has
gone up however the price is very high
the reliability is very low and this
provides a strong structural incentive
to direct investments into Renewables
and Energy Efficiency let's talk briefly
about the Here and Now uh what are the
consequences the immediate consequences
of this Resurgence of coal
well first of all what happened through
Russia's aggression against Ukraine is
that the largest fossil fuel exporter
has shut down partially or been shut
down so this explains why there is a
scramble to substitute those exports so
essentially we're trying to mobilize
other supplies but on the global level
if we look at the coal consumption
there's multiple reasons driving this
Effect one reason also is a severe
drought in Asia which has led to a
reduced availability of hydropower so we
see the consequences of the climate
crisis as one element what needs to
happen now is very clear that the
Investments for New Generation
facilities go into renewable energies
for example it's also a huge opportunity
for a country like South Africa that's
been struggling structurally to meet its
electricity demand and when it comes to
these Investments the International
Energy agency says that a global funding
in clean energy sources could Rise by
fifty percent in the coming years if
Investments go ahead as planned is there
enough incentive for these plans to
materialize briefly if you could
yes why because fossil fuels currently
are very expensive the supply is fairly
unreliable a vast number of countries
experiencing this right now coal
deliveries aren't coming and so this
provides a strong incentive for
switching over and that's why the
international energy has come to this
conclusion
Simon Miller energy transition expert
thank you so much
next